je crois qu'ils chantent discussion ils
sont encore ouverts nous savons que
l'intervention du premier ministre ne
l'est pas tout résoudre en dise qu'on
résout pas tout mais il apporte des
clarifications sont extrêmement fortes
sur le caractère universel du système
sur les modalités pratiques de mise en
oeuvre avec le report par rapport aux
préconisations à la génération 75 pour
le régime général mais ta volonté aussi
d'apporter des nouveaux droits comme un
minimum contributif pour toutes celles
et ceux qui ont cotisé pendant toute
leur carrière dès 2022 à hauteur de 85%
du smic plutôt que de 75 % aujourd'hui
après il faut que nous puissions assurer
cet équilibre les tulipes du système
c'est là que le premier ministre dit
qu'il y a une méthode qui consiste à
avoir un âge équilibre avec un bonus et
un malus tu celui-ci peut-être
progressif mais qu'il ya aussi une
discussion à voir dans la gouvernance
avec les partenaires sociaux pour voir
s'il ya d'autres trajectoires qui
permettent d'assurer cet équilibre donc
par exemple sur cette date de 2000 27
pour 7h d'équilibré à 64 ans il est il
et il est fixe il vous pourrez bouger
sur ce sur 7 initialement l'objectif
était d'avoir un équilibre en 2025
au début du nouveau système parce qu'il
est plus logique d'entrer dans un
système en étant un équilibre qui
entrait dans un système en ayant déjà
une dette comme un boulet au pied
le premier ministre a ouvert cette porte
jusqu'en 2027 pour une entrée provisoire
progressif pardonnez moi ça lui posait
un lapsus pour une entrée qui soit aussi
progressive par rapport à l'année de
naissance dans la mesure où il ya eu un
recul de manière à pouvoir aller moins
brutalement plus doucement et emporté le
maximum de monde avec nous au delà de
cela il y avait une donnée 2025 et une
bascule de système et il ya une année
à partir de laquelle nous allons mettre
en place de nouveaux droits notamment
sur le minimum contributif ou pour la
revalorisation d'un certain nombre de
métiers comme les enseignants alors une
question sur les fonctionnaires parce
que vous êtes un e secrétaire d'état qui
travaille beaucoup sur sur les agents de
la fonction publique il ya un coup de
pouce pour les enseignants notamment
aussi pour les aides soignants mais pour
les autres fonctionnaires ce sont les
grands perdants de cette réforme ce ne
sont pas les perdants le fonctionnaire
pour une raison très simple
jusqu'à présent les fonctionnaires
cotisent sur leur traitement indiciaire
et non pas sur leurs primes ou alors de
manière très marginale cette réforme
propose d'intégrer les primes dans
l'assiette de cotisation pour faire en
sorte que la retraite des fonctionnaires
leur pension soit calculé véritablement
sur la réalité de leurs revenus et pas
sur un revenu aux et des primes et
en cela c'est un vrai progrès c'est une
attente forte
nous avions dit deux choses qu'il
fallait veiller à ce qu'aucun
fonctionnaire ne soit perdons pour les
enseignants il s'agit de revaloriser les
carrières et nous avions dit qu'il
fallait revaloriser
la rémunération des enseignants en même
temps qu'en mettant en oeuvre la réforme
le premier ministre a proposé que la
revalorisation pour les enseignants
soient discutées début 2020 et qu'elle
s'applique dès 2021 soit quatre ans
avant le début de la réforme ce qui est
aussi un geste significatif pour les
aides soignantes en particulier nous
savons que nous devons mieux tenir
compte de la pénibilité ce qui me
demandent la cfdt faire en sorte de
mieux prendre en compte le travail de
nuit à miner les règles sur le privé
parce qu'il a des différences entre 8
heures et 10 heures de nuit et puis
surtout nous proposons pour celles qui
le souhaiteraient celles et ceux qui le
souhaiteraient d'utiliser les comptes et
pas longtemps pour pouvoir aménager les
fins de carrière
travailler à temps partiel en étant
rémunéré à ton plein puisque ce sont des
joueurs qui sont dues par l'employeur
mais de manière régulière pour
progressivement aller vers la retraite
dans de bonnes conditions en fin de
carrière très bien